قواعد اللعبه تغيرت في حرب اوكرانيا
والصراع دخل منعرجا اخر فاكيف نزعت ثوب
الخجل وتجرات على الاراضي الروسيه بل
وضربتها في العمق هذا ما كشفت عنه موت
كلته اعلانات عن تعرض قاعدتين جويتين
تقعان في عمق الروسي الى هجمات نفذت طائره
مسيره اوكرانيه ما اسفر عن سقوط ثلاثه في
صفوف الجيش الروسيه ليكون هذا الهجوم
الاكثر جراه اذن من كاف وهو ما اكدته ايضا
صحيفه تايمز التي ذكرت تقلا عن مسؤول
اوكراني انا المسرات ثم نطلقها من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وذلك بمساعده القوات الخاصه
فما هي هذه التقنيه التي قد تغير قواعد
اللعبه في الحرب في اوك عليها
الحديث هنا مشاهدينا عن مسيرات طورتها
اوكرانيا خصوصا لانجاز مهمات داخل العمق
الروسي فبحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان
هذه المسيارات التي سادفت المواقع الروسيه
هي سوفياتيه الصنع وهي ما يتماشى مع
الادوات التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا في تصنيع
الاسلحه ونقلا عن صحيفه
الاوكرانيه الجديده يبلغ مداها 1000 كيلو
متر ومن المرجح ان هذه المصيرات هي من صنع
شركه
للاسلحه المملوكه للدوله والتي كشفت في
مناسبه السابقه عن تطوير طائره بدون طياره
بعيده المدى